[Music]
uh so the uh
rhode island department of
transportation had to acknowledge on
tuesday that they uh they had a little
oopsy daisy oopsy daisy yeah they um
they they probably have a ton with that
shitty ass weather oh dude got frozen
roads every day not good over there not
good that must be rough huh yep but they
accidentally oopsie daisy uh paved a
highway over a cemetery containing the
remains of one thousand oh [ __ ] rhode
islanders
is that a lawsuit all the way for sure
right
yo
accidentally that road is about to be
haunted they better [ __ ] break that
[ __ ] apart before it solidifies yeah i
bet you that [ __ ] was not an [ __ ]
that's some poltergeist [ __ ] right i bet
you that's not an accident
that's a ghost like just rich ass people
they're like hey look [ __ ] it we gotta
let's see the bigger picture is like a
thousand dead people aren't gonna really
do anything about it versus like we do
this and a thousand years from now
nobody's gonna say [ __ ]
but wasn't there like there's gotta be
like tombstones there right like they
just they probably blocked it let's just
put the cement over the tombstone yeah
what's the oops that is some vulture
guys [ __ ] yeah that's how ghosts happen
bro it's it's the burial grounds
governor dan mckee described the
incident as a little oopsy daisy how are
you gonna oopsie daisy you swear to god
it's like a direct quote [ __ ] i
don't even know how to spell it oopsie
daisy bro
and he says what we had what we had here
it appears to be a little oopsie
use it in twice in uh in one speech
i think how do you reference
[Music]
there were no stone heads
uh
it was like one of those like where the
flat they had black cards or whatever so
what do you think is gonna happen in the
future when there's full like graveyards
of no more remaining family members it's
just a big plot of land with dead people
that's like so ancient that no one even
knows what the [ __ ] to do like like
right here rose hills or whatever right
like
300 maybe 500 years from now is that
just going to be like a historical like
graveyard or do you think people are
still going to be
buried there like
on top of you they'll still be buried
there because we have like civil war
graveyard still really people still go
and visit i do they still continue to
bury civilians in like these like it's
not a memorial they probably will but
they'll probably have a couple oopsy
daisy
little oopsies yeah like what would you
do like when you when you want to move
like a plot and like if they know that
this whole area right there's no more
family members they're not even paying
rent on this corner no more it's just a
bunch of skeletons
and and what are they going to do they
dig them up and they move them yeah
that's what they do yeah
so like if you want to move it then
they'll dig up they'll take the casket
out and then move it somewhere else so
recently i was talking to my dad about
um like the rose hill stuff and he was
saying when he first got his plot of
land it was like i think seven g's or
something in the 90s
or his brother and then so when he got
it he got it for like 11 g's in early
2000s
and then now he said the market price
for this just one slot is like 20 g's
it's like real estate and then when you
get one of those like um
what are those things called where it's
like you could get a whole family buried
together not [ __ ]
or um
mausoleum mausoleum um those things are
like a million dollars per
[ __ ] house
i'm like that's why you know they're
it's a ball and family when you have
those big ass [ __ ] arcs yeah like
holy holy whole thing and it says the
something family because i was trying to
be all boss during dinner my dad's cause
he's trying to figure out he's gonna
move to vegas or not he goes oh what
about my plots of land i'm like don't
i'll cover that [ __ ] and he goes you
can't afford it i'm like trust me i'll
[ __ ] cover that [ __ ] he goes the
mausoleums are a million dollars like oh
[ __ ] cuz we gotta be thinking
[Laughter]
i thought it was gonna be like i thought
it would be like okay if we have three
uncles maybe 10 g's a piece i was like
40 g's i'll [ __ ] cover that [ __ ] but
then he was like
i'll get one of those things up build it
and he's like no it's a million dollars
and i'm like
he already bought it already no it's
just him it's my my grandpa
uh my uncle's buried there my
uh other uncle is gonna get buried there
my dad's gonna get buried so there's
gonna be four blocks of land is in
burial is that family should be close
together like that yeah they're trying
to
oh
damn dude they're trying to get us close
together as possible one [ __ ] casket
do four slots yeah dude four bodies
stack them up like that like a shelf oh
yeah you know just dig up your grandpa
make sure that they get
boom and then you get one plot of land
you gotta get the deals even in death
it's like a bunk bed but with caskets
maybe there's gonna be some random
societal mass adoption for like
cremation at a certain point
my family did some chinese [ __ ] where my
grandpa passed away
um so you're only supposed to put one
person per plot right when my grandpa
passed away literally seconds before
they closed the casket my other uncle
came and grabbed my grandma's ashes and
just put it in the casket so they just
loaded it in so that's pretty fire so
what do you mean seconds before like
literally like he wasn't allowed to
they're like oopsie daisy
who made the buzzer dude like a ceremony
it's there's a hole is there they can
have the puzzle
they they put it over right and then
there's a [ __ ] chain
lowers it in right so you kind of have
your last moments and everyone's like
he's like
and they [ __ ] just lowered it and
then on the tombstone that's printed it
has my
grandma's name and my grandpa's name but
they pay for one person's price that's
awesome they just dig it back up later
keep on putting urns inside i think
that's the move though i mean that's
what they do in japan they don't have
full body caskets everything is
everyone's cremated
yeah and then when what they do is
you'll get like a a stone stone head or
whatever but it's a huge [ __ ] one
right and then under that plot of land
they bury the same family members
in that same same area they're all
cremated so it's smaller yeah in the in
the graveyards are small like they're
not like rose hill size they're like the
size of maybe
one like
half a eight not not even a quarter acre
like like the size of a home here but
that's why the japanese people got all
the crazy ghosts and [ __ ] though because
it's like
you put all the cremation together and
the dust turns into a gangster ghoul
then you get the grudge and [ __ ] in
taiwan it doesn't matter what your
religion is you have to get cremated
it's because of it's the island right
there's no space yeah japan too would
you guys go what's your optimal way of
being
uh drop me off dump me in a disneyland
river dude
i
[Laughter]
he wants to mummify himself
do you want your remains to be mixed
with the concrete or whatever that'll be
kind of cool right i don't care about my
remains because i feel like when i die
this body is just not me that that's
what i think is well it's like i don't
need to have like a casket or anything
like you could say some space and
exactly what we're gonna do
mike's eternal bro michael's like rest
me with my victims
scatter me throughout all my burials of
my victims i want to be with them i want
to find photos of mike throughout
history the guy's a [ __ ] vampire is
it immortal you're a day walker bro
what is this concept he's like yeah
whatever
400 years old mike sits here with us
he's like i'll watch all of you die yeah
old age
has been aged ever since we met him he's
one of those guys like burdened with
immortality you know what he means
it's like you think you think this is
fun wait until you see all your loved
ones die six centuries ago yeah he's
like i've had nine wives
i've been trying husband
he's out of all kinds bro to add to that
though i would probably want to get
cremated pre-made and then what happens
with your ashes
dusted in a kind of stew oh what the
hell just do you have to be here
yeah buy buy your kids crude
noodles oh [ __ ] he's
[Laughter]
was it the legend of tupac or something
like that like getting burnt and then uh
rolling them up in a blunt and smoking
the blood that'd be tight i forget what
that was that's very anthony lee style i
think what about you bart i didn't just
cremate it and throw them back in nature
yeah me too yeah so i could be one with
the earths because when i'm dead i'm
done and i feel like at that point the
people it's just a matter of time of
people that know you they're gonna die
yeah
people and if you did something great
maybe you'll be like
you'll be a legend for a while but
how long will that legend last unless
it's like
what you're one of the greats you know
maybe when when people like burn my body
creamy like i'll have that film turn
into like an nft oh that's a bomb
really that'll be tight you get out
there on the polygon blockchain hell
yeah what if it's only worth a dollar
well you know
[ __ ]
but it's probably worth one more dollar
than it would have been just as ashes so
like not bad right smart contract
anybody who purchased this can you know
[ __ ] die in the same way
you know what's crazy though to think
about like immortality is like
all the all this stuff we're uploading
on youtube right now right they have so
much data of our thoughts our
personality our point of view whatever
they could replicate another
one of us by all the hours if they
download like all of our vlogs all of
our videos what we've said over the
years
and it's like just create a database of
that human being in the future they just
like try to recreate all of us but they
really just make him a serial killer
oh yeah he's like dude he was the serial
killer right you ever see that clip of
kim kardashian having a hologram and
it's her [ __ ] dad oh
dad is like talking to kim kardashian
like as if he's like i'm so proud of all
the things you've accomplished and it's
like him as rob kardashian and it's like
it's and she's like crying the whole
family's like going nuts but it is kind
of creepy i'll [ __ ] up the scientists
that did that to me wait wasn't that
like kanye's present to her or something
something yeah yeah that's crazy wait
kanye's present that's why yeah i don't
know this was like a couple years ago
wasn't it i remember watching the video
and then the whole family is sitting
there
watching this hologram of robert
kardashian that's a boost so pretty much
what robert downey jr does at the end of
adventures pretty much dude spoiler
alert some real avengers type of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
do you know what do you think happens at
the end of avengers i don't know i
didn't get there yet they eat [ __ ]
shawarma
[Laughter]
[ __ ] people you've seen the uh the
first one
no no i just started i finished so i'm
finished winter soldier
i'm on to uh
i'm on to
what oh i meant the one where uh i think
he's back at toby maguire's fight
thanos's three
old sidekick
was that fool's name skinny old sidekick
the guy with the the voodoo stuff yeah
he just comes in like he he could just
go like this and don't worry
you're infinity war i'm not if anyone is
that the last one no second one that's
the second to last that's a good one
yeah infinity war is really good
actually i like that more than in-game
robert kardashian hologram
whoa that's [ __ ] was that 3d or was
that in video
i don't know oh that was like tupac
coming to life right i think so yeah he
did it with the hologram tech this is
the hologram that's crazy
see i think it's creepy because he's
like colored like that if they would
have made him kind of princess like
you know come in like r2d2 style you
know
where it's like hey this is a memory
this isn't like recreate human you know
like obi-wan is being projected and [ __ ]
yeah if you're watching this it's like
slightly like you could see the the rays
that create the vision of it he looks
like a call of duty character
he does yeah it does a skin
[Music]